-What I like about your show
is it's very honest.
It's this kind of thing.
You don't lie to your audience
And they know that.
-I was talking to Eric Holde
behind the scenes back there
-Yeah.
-He's coming out a little later.
-So, he was like, "Oh, my gosh
You're like you are
on your show."
I was like,
"Well, what do you want?"
-Yeah.
-Nobody has time to act.
-Yeah. Also, this --
I would -- It would be very --
I feel like you can only be you.
Is that accurate?
-Seth.
-Yes.
-Believe me.
-Yeah.
-I can only be me.
-Yeah. And I'm so glad.
What is this? Season 11?
-11.
-Amazing.
Congratulations on that.
-I never thought
it would last, honestly.
-Yeah, 11 is a big deal.
-It is. Well, it's not --
I mean, 10 is a good number.
11 is kind of a weird number
-Well, don't make me feel ba
about saying 11 is a big deal.
-But 11. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-You also -- I don't think
people fully appreciate
how multitalented you are.
You've written a series of books
before you had your show.
-Yes.
-Ritz Harper was the character
And I feel like Ritz Harpe
was maybe slightly based,
inspired by Wendy Williams
-Certainly.
-There was "Ritz Harper
Goes to Hollywood."
-Well, that's me posing as Ritz.
-Yeah.
-Mm-hmm. [ Laughs ]
-This is another
Ritz Harper book.
"Drama is Her Middle Name.
-That was the first one
of the Ritz. That's correct.
-I got to say,
this made me laugh so hard
-Okay.
-I haven't stopped laughing.
-That is me with
ketchup sprayed around me.
-And the title of
this Ritz Harper book is
"Is the Bitch Dead or What?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean --
-The thing about Ritz --
Ritz is a fabulous New York City
disc jockey
who happens to get a talk show
-Oh, wow.
So it's really close to home
-But -- And so I have this -
I'm in bed with Lifetime.
Not in bed, nut, you know.
-Yeah, yeah.
-With Lifetime right now.
And I would like to see Ritz
either as a series or a movie.
But my first project is
going to be my own life story.
-Oh, you're going to do a
Lifetime movie about yourself,
your life story?
-Oh, believe me you.
-Are you gonna -- Is it
gonna be a documentary
or is it gonna be a narrative?
-Okay. Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
They're doing two hours
for the movie
and then two hours
for the documentary.
-Oh, my God. So who's going to
play you in the movie?
-Four hours of me.
-Yeah.
-On Lifetime.
-Are they -- How can they cast
Wendy Williams?
Are you going to play yourself
-No, no. No.
I'm producing.
-Yeah.
-I got no time to act.
-Yeah, of course. Hands off.
-Yeah, yeah.
But here's the thing.
No. I want to hire actors
that no one knows.
Because, really, you know,
there's a message in it.
I mean, we can laugh
and joke all day, Seth.
-We can, yes.
-But in actuality,
I've been doing this -- I've had
a microphone for over 30 years
-Uh-huh.
-You know what I mean?
And I've done the best I can
with what I had.
And what I have is, you know
my parents don't come
from, you know, nepotism,
you know, like, making a phone
call, getting Wendy in the door.
I've fought for everything
And I've never been MeToo'd.
You know, I --
Respect to all the girls
who, you know,
are going through that.
I've never done that.
I don't even know what that is
You know,
I fight, punch, hustle.
Even right now, you know,
going through a public divorce
while I'm still a big mout
doing hot topics.
I'm talking about people
when I'm being talked about.
It's me against the world.
-Well, I feel as though th
world is getting a beating
You've been doing great.
Congratulations
on all your success.
And let me tell you,
it is always such a pleasure
to have you here.
-You're kicking me out?
-I'm kicking you out.
Wendy Williams, everybody.